[Música]
momento de nuestra revista de prensa
esta mañana con Marta Moya Marta Buenos
días para usted Buenos días Ángela y
vamos a abrir esta sección con un
reportaje del medio estadounidense New
York Times el que aborda las
alternativas que está proponiendo China
para incentivar la natalidad después de
años de políticas como sabemos muy muy
restrictivas Así es Ángela como sabemos
No pues durante décadas se impulsó la
política del hijo único después en 2016
el gobierno chino amplió esa política a
dos hijos y luego el 2021 hasta tres
hijos por pareja este mes de febrero en
la región de sichuan que es la quinta
región más poblada de china con 84
millones de habitantes pues han empezado
a quitar las restricciones ya bueno
impulsar estas medidas para que el país
siga creciendo no y que las mujeres
tengan tantos hijos como deseen Incluso
si son madres solteras Este es un
invento desesperado de China por
impulsar ese baby Boom
Pues que de que china Pues el año pasado
por primera vez Viera su población
envejecida desde por primera vez desde
1960 también según recoge este artículo
del New York Times pues esto pone de
manifiesto que la crisis demográfica al
final está haciendo que el partido
comunista abandone un poco ese férreo
control que tenía sobre los derechos
reproductivos de las mujeres y las
propuestas alternativas que propone el
gobierno chino son por primera vez
instar a los jóvenes universitarios a
que donen esperma y luego por otra parte
ampliar la cobertura de los seguros para
que pues los tratamientos de fertilidad
se puedan cubrir por parte del Estado
incluso la fecundación in vitro
concretamente en sichuan en esta región
donde se ha eliminado totalmente la el
control a la natalidad pues va a
impulsar una licencia parental pagada y
además se van a reembolsar las facturas
del hospital sin embargo la medida se ha
recogido con escepticismo porque pues
china es uno países del Mundo donde más
caro es criar a un niño y además dice
los chinos que pues no se ofrecen
alternativas para pues la educación la
vivienda o la salud y además tampoco se
ofrecen alternativas para cuidar a los
adultos mayores no es que para nada es
suficiente y no solamente en China sino
en todo el mundo las mujeres tienen cada
vez menos incentivos para las
maternidades por Pues porque implica
muchas cargas para su futuro profesional
entre otras cosas Marta y esto lo traigo
a colación porque la cuestión es de las
políticas de incentivo en la natalidad
ponen mucho enfoco a las mujeres que
sabemos si asumimos una gran carga y
parece que ahora la cosa puede cambiar
para las chinas Así es Ángela tal cual y
un ejemplo es que bueno pues las
políticas en sichuan no solo van a
aplicar a las parejas casadas sino
también a las familias monoparentales y
esto por primera vez china al final es
un país donde las mujeres solteras han
sufrido históricamente mucha
discriminación se les ha negado
sistemáticamente los beneficios y las
ayudas que tenían las parejas casadas e
incluso las mujeres pues por ejemplo no
tenían miedo a quedarse embarazadas
porque tenían miedo a ser despedidas
Incluso en algunas provincias las
mujeres solteras quedaban a luz asumían
multas económicas no esto También recibe
críticas por parte de los chinos porque
muchos creen que las medidas llegan
tarde y que por otra parte se incentivan
los hombres a que tengan hijos con sus
amantes y también recoge este artículo
del New Times para cerrar que pues a
raíz de esta relajación de las políticas
de natalidad se ha empezado a bromear en
redes sociales con que por fin los
hombres pueden asumir un poco más de
carga que han asumido históricamente las
mujeres con esta incentivación de las
campañas de donación de semen pero es
que es vergonzoso la verdad Marta vamos
a cambiar de tema y Vamos hasta la
prensa italiana porque el naufragio de
una embarcación rota dejó el domingo al
menos entre 60 y ya las últimas cifras
hablaban de 62 migrantes fallecidos y
esto ha resucitado el debate sobre las
responsabilidades del gobierno y de la
Unión Europea respecto crisis migratoria
que ha estado mucho tiempo fuera de los
titulares qué es lo que dicen Así vamos
empezamos con el correre de la acera que
rescata los testimonios de algunos de
los supervivientes de esta tragedia en
crotone en el sur de Italia que deja ya
como decías al menos 62 muertos entre
otras cosas los supervivientes dicen que
estaban en la embarcación a eso de las 5
de la mañana y que esos
contrabandistas vieron luces en la costa
y que pensaron que eran la guarda
costera Y decidieron cambiar el rumbo de
la embarcación cuando estaban apenas a
500 metros de Tierra Firme no pero que
en ese ánimo de cambiar rápidamente de
dirección tuvieron que aligerar el peso
de La Barca y echaron al menos 20
personas por la borda en ese momento
cambiaron la dirección y dice uno de los
testimonios que escuchamos un ruido muy
fuerte cuando se quiebra esa Barca Y
ella dice esta mujer que recogemos el
testimonio que estaba abrazando a su
marido y después cuando lo encontraron
en el mar nunca más lo volvió a también
recoge el testimonio de otra chica de 16
años que viajaba con su hermana de 28
que lamentablemente falleció también y
en la República destaca Pues que al
final todos los líderes políticos
condenan lo ocurrido pero cada quien
Pues con ciertos matices no Sergio
matarrela echa la culpa a la Unión
Europea que dice que tiene que gestionar
estos asuntos Georgia melón y al final
Pues sigue destacando su política
antimigratoria desde la Unión Europea
dice que tiene que haber acuerdos con
los países de orígenes que trasladan a
estos migrantes Y por último las ong
destacan que al final todo esto es
consecuencia Ángela de las políticas que
desarrolla Italia cuando no deja entrar
a los migrantes en Puerto seguros lo
mismo de siempre y de Guardián
rápidamente Marta afirma que Grecia
fortifica su frontera con Turquía para
evitar el paso descontrolado de los
migrantes después de los terremotos del
seis de febrero Así es Ángela y es que
se va se va a reforzar Perdón por tierra
y por aire Esto es lo que ha decidido el
gobierno griego este fin de semana ya
han empezado patrullar según de Guardian
decenas de centenares de nuevos guardas
costeros en la frontera terrestre y
también Grecia va a comprar a comprar
barcos guardacostas para patrullar en el
Mar Egeo e impedir que los migrantes
lleguen desde Turquía y Siria pues Marta
Muchas gracias a usted Muchas gracias
Ángela hasta mañana